and the first thing i'll ask you is what
you had for breakfast this morning so i
can test the volume on it what that i
had i had rice puffs and banana and uh
earl grey tea and fresh orange juice i
didn't have anything for breakfast
i'm a coffee drinker coffee sustains me
it keeps you productive was the banana
on the rice puffs yes it was i slice it
up into tiny little pieces breakfast
what's that i just got out of bed i had
cream of wheat with brown sugar cream of
wheat i didn't even know what that is i
used the last milk in the house so
almost none left for tea but it was okay
for breakfast this morning i had oatmeal
i nearly always have oatmeal for
breakfast do you have anything on it
like sweetener or anything or do you
have it just no i have oatmeal and then
on the side i have soy yogurt okay
testing
what do i have starbucks blueberry
blueberry scone
nice yeah
oh yeah every morning seven get up get
out do stuff uh egg bread
like a coffee egg and bread did you
toast it
or plain bread
oh no no i toasted it
yeah i had rolled oats and uh bananas
and i really got coffee which is how i
have to start my day every morning good
coffee
and of course
cranberries porridge and bananas little
bit of dates and some wheat bran
actually i missed breakfast this morning
um which was uh yeah in fact i haven't
eaten yet today at all no
sometimes this happens
is this thing on
yeah but i did have a curry at
approximately um half past 12 last night
so really what were you still digesting
sauce
bacon and
potatoes
and it was all not good since me
discussing my breakfast from this
morning which was not the breakfast the
hotel offered us because they wanted to
have a a natural number
of our english pounds in exchange for
that breakfast and obviously how many
pounds weird order of 20 i had eggs and
cinnamon toast 20 20 20 pounds for
breakfast about to say they better they
better chop it into bite-sized pieces
and put it in my mouth for me for 20
quid a bit of test what do you have for
breakfast this morning
usually easily usually yep okay so i got
up and i had uh oatmeal at about five in
the morning yeah oatmeal and coffee in
the morning oh i had
cereal and coffee and then my daughter
woke up a little bit after five and i
made her a coffee uh let's see i had
coffee and a bit of a smoothie
uh hello hello hey hey hey hey
let me ask you what you had for
breakfast this morning
no memory i actually i do it though
what did you have let's see what did i
have for breakfast
cereal with lots of fruit
i le i had all the leftovers from the
kids
uh i had some toast just toast just
toast yeah what'd you have on it uh
peanut butter what's the recipe today
jim on two test test test i'm probably
not switched on
breakfast i i had a bacon panini
apparently what did i have breakfast
some salmon and rice
and and she bought me some coffee didn't
she she did
for breakfast today i had two weetabix
two yes why not three
because then i would end up with an odd
number actually you know i don't care
about the coffee very much
um but um
yeah i
do drink it a bit of a sound check
professor what'd you do for breakfast
this morning oh
yogurt and fruit
more mangoes really did you have rum on
them
i was i was yearning for that but uh no
porridge porridge with milk bananas and
blueberries oatmeal oatmeal would you
put anything on huh uh raspberries and
milk well i don't usually generally eat
anything in the morning
i know but i yeah but i exercise a lot i
exercise for two hours and then i ate
lunch so especially when i'm running
late i thought you're not supposed to
exercise when you're on an empty stomach
well i've been exercising for 50 years
so i do it the way i want to do it i'm
going to do what you do because it seems
to be working
hello what'd you have for breakfast
um i did some maths for breakfast you
did massive breakfast yeah